[Musique]
bonsoir et bienvenue dans ce nouveau
numéro du service culture je vous
souhaite à tous une très belle année
voici le sommaire de ce premier numéro
de l'année le théâtre Montansier de
Versailles accueillera mercredi 12
janvier Les Trois Brigands adapté du
comte de Tomi Ungerer cette pièce de
théâtre est à découvrir en famille les
nuits de la lecture viennent pour une 6e
édition la communauté urbaine de Grand
Paris Seine-et-Oise propose de
nombreuses animations du 20 au 23
janvier dans différentes bibliothèque
nous parlerons de ces manifestations et
ateliers avec la responsable de cet
événement pour GPS et oh et puis enfin à
Saint-Germain-en-Laye le musée
départemental Maurice Denis fait le
Nouvel An japonais au programme des
spectacles des ateliers et des
conférences il sera joué au théâtre
Montansier mercredi 12 janvier à 15h
l'adaptation Les Trois Brigands mettant
lumière des voyous et leur destin croisé
avec une petite fille un spectacle qui
agit théâtre musique ou encore
marionnettes regarder
adaptation de l'album de jeunesse de
Tomi Ungerer Les Trois Brigands c'est
l'histoire de trois voyous qui chaque
soir des trousses des voyageurs un
spectacle qui tourne autour de la
rencontre avec une petite orpheline des
protagonistes que tout oppose
qu'est-ce qui va naître de cette
rencontre et comment c'est trois
brigands vont vont comment cette petite
fille va finalement bouleversé la vie de
C3 de C3 de C3 affreux jojo
et comment ils vont trouver une
implication sociale différente il veut
pas dire qu'il arrête de voler
[Musique]
spectacle à 5 ans contre lui par la
compagnie les muettes bavarder la
compagnie les petites Donkey shot au
programme marionnette Théâtre et uni
mention musical apporter au conte
musical qui fait venir au théâtre un
grand compositeur
il avait jamais composer pour pour la
pour elle les paroles pour des textes
donc je pense que c'est c'est des grands
interprètes aussi Sébastien innocente
ils sont très
reconnu aujourd'hui à l'international
rendez-vous au Théâtre du Montansier
mercredi 12 janvier à 15h pour découvrir
le spectacle
et d'autres spectacle sont aussi à
découvrir dans les Yvelines les 21 22 et
23 janvier les frères colle seront sur
la scène du cabaret du bout des prés à
Cernay-la-Ville finaliste 2021 de la
France a un Incroyable Talent sur M6 ce
trio fraternel où vous emportera dans
l'univers de la jonglerie avec humour et
musique les 60 choristes de la troupe de
gospel white-spirit présentent leur
grand concert annuel de dimanche 16
janvier 2022 à 15h30 de grands
classiques sont repris comme goût de
Moïse au plus récemment plus récent
comme get happy à l'église de Notre-Dame
du Chesnay à Viroflay avec les nouvelles
règles mise en vigueur par le
gouvernement ce lundi 3 janvier qui
impose de rester assis pendant les
spectacles certaines salon du reporter
voir annuler des concerts c'est le cas
pour la bouffe de la batterie à
Guyancourt avec l'annulation de la date
du jeune rappeur canoë prévu le 14
janvier pour les autres rendez-vous au
de la salle des chaises sont installés à
la place de la Fosse à l'âne attrape le
groupe Tryo reporte sa tournée a prévu
le 30 janvier prochain dans la salle
trappiste pour le reste tout et pour
l'instant maintenu
le musée départemental Maurice Denis
fête le nouvel an en japonais du 15 au
30 janvier des spectacles conférence ou
encore ateliers sont organisés pour
célébrer les nombres liens qui unissent
le musée et le Japon on en parle avec
Pierre-Marie Vautier chargé de médiation
culturelle
gâteau c'est ainsi qu'à la fois de
spectacle de conférence et date liés
qu'on donne pour fêter le Nouvel An
japonais et un événement au Japon qui se
déroule sur sur plusieurs jours et que
au musée on célébrera entre le 15
janvier et le 30
janvier et on a la chance d'être
patronne et par l'ambassade du Japon
personnellement il avait plusieurs amis
japonais et il a notamment eu des élèves
japonais qui sont devenus peintre
reconnu au Japon mais c'est sûr surtout
l'influence japonaise qui est très
présente dans son œuvre
on aura 2 temps forts principalement
j'ai sont les journées du 16 janvier et
du 30 janvier où on aura des artiste
traditionnel japonais qui viendront à
représenter du théâtre Tyco du coup des
tambours
traditionnel japonais de la dans ce cas
bougie ce sont des performances en
général à 6 course suivi d'un temps
d'explication et puis également ce
seront tous nos ateliers par nos
plasticien plutôt pour les familles et
les enfants autour du manga autour de
l'essence autour de l'origami
du 20 au 23 janvier prochain et c'est la
6e édition et des nuits de la lecture
sur 4 soirée avec un temps fort le
samedi 22 janvier les médiathèque
bibliothèque librairie ou encore musée
proposeront des animations pour vous
faire partager le plaisir de lire Sonia
à la Thiers Bonsoir vous êtes
vous êtes en vidéo conférence avec nous
à vous êtes la responsable de la
bibliothèque des Mureaux alors avant de
parler de ce qui se déroulera dans votre
bibliothèque parle peut-être de
l'événement concrètement concrètement à
quoi sert les nuit de la lecture
à valoriser le livre à le faire voir
autrement à donner envie à tous les
lecteurs à tous les usagers de d'aller
vers la lecture
merveilleux pour s'évader apprendre
devenir citoyen donc c'est une un coup
de projecteur sur tout le travail que
j'ai fait dans les bibliothèques
librairie
principalement
notamment chez les jeunes la lecture le
goût de la lecture n'est plus forcément
la comment vous faites du coup pour
redonner l'envie de lire
alors on propose des animations qui
sortent un peu de l'ordinaire et qui
sont en lien avec le livre notamment des
escape game par exemple des jeux des
mains d'or partie des animations des
clopes
et
après en fin de compte j'ai les jeunes
lis quand même
voilà c'est tous des animations qui sort
de l'ordinaire qu'on peut proposer pour
attirer les jeunes lecteurs
oui justement gps en de nombreuses
événement physique et aussi en numérique
un sont proposés donc dans aussi dans
les bibliothèques est-ce que vous pouvez
peut-être citer quelques-uns les plus
importants
sur tout là j'ai pesso il y aura
beaucoup d'événements par exemple à
Mantes-la-Jolie il y aura des piges
acompte théâtrale
il y aura des pizzas compte dans 100 des
lecture en pyjama des sorties au Théâtre
des
ateliers créatifs
numérique et où
as-tu traditionnelle des escape game des
concerts
de théâtre voilà
d'animation qu'on pourra trouver l'
heure de nuit de la lecture dans les
différentes bibliothèque de la
communauté urbaine Grand Paris
Seine-et-Oise
fait partie de la bibliothèque
justement vous avez mis en place
nous il y aura deux ateliers un atelier
carte pop-up créer son personnage de BD
ou manga préféré en 3D ça c'est plus
pour les plus grands à partir de 8 ans
pour les plus petits 4 septembre il y
aura un atelier pêle-mêle où ce sont des
petits livres ou qui sont découpés par
bandes horizontales mélanger la tête le
corps les pieds et un atelier mélange
rat
création manuelle et numérique
on est
le 22 janvier
parti en 2020 pour voir la l'état de la
planète en 2050 chirurgienne il faut
voir ce qui s'est passé le trouver les
énigmes et c'est une animation qu'on
propose en lien avec un par
l'association énergie solidaire
et
on sera là avec plaisir merci beaucoup
le centre
de Londres est
une exposition vivante et éclectique
jusqu'au 14 janvier
un cheval rose à bascule une machine à
laver ou encore un instrument de musique
originale l'exposition ce que Malek va
être présenté au centre d'art de Londres
de Vélizy-Villacoublay le collectif le
Wonder créé en 2013 à travailler avec le
théâtre pour réaliser ses œuvre ce
groupe d'artistes habite des bâtiments
inoccupé
espace Unity lisez en atelier pour le
pour travailler le bois le métal
impression la peinture l'enjeu pour le
monde à chaque fois c'est de sortir un
peu l'exposition de son car quand on
va dire où il y a cette visite
solennelle qui l'a se transforme en
quelque chose qui vient de cuisine en
folie
12 articles qui ont texto c'est une
petite quinzaine d'offres totalement
différente où tous les sens sont en
éveil elles sont tout de même deux
points en commun être expérimentale est
destiné en public plutôt jeune l'idée
c'était vraiment d'apporter une
dimension ludique c'est pas un collectif
qui travaille spécialement pour le jeune
public donc c'était vraiment une demande
une commande du centre d'art et de Léo
qui touche aussi c'est public donc ils
sont vraiment amusé avec sa mason permis
de cristal mettre en 2017 une œuvre
hypnotisante une boule disco accroché au
plafond qui crée un frottement sur le
sol
c'est de la mettre en jeu à Londres s'il
te plaît encore une fois il est très
très haut donc dans ces questions aussi
une très grande fille qui descendait
pour venir et épouser la danse de cette
boule disco sur le sol qui vient en fait
c'est miroir et se briser un miroir dans
un espèce de bruit de scratch de vinyle
produit à une fille une poussière de
miroir argenté
comme un mur du son lit tiroir qui
s'ouvre et se ferme en rythme et encore
une ruche de culture de champignons tout
et réalisation sont à découvrir jusqu'au
14 janvier prochain
et c'est la fin de cette fille de
culture merci de nous avoir suivi
rendez-vous la semaine prochaine bonne
soirée sur TV 70
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]